back now to the charges filed against
president Trump's former campaign chair
and his deputy in the special councils
Russia probe Judge Napolitano thinks
this is just the beginning of much more
to come this is the first of many
dominoes to fall that he is fob Muller
is following the standard mo of federal
prosecutors you got a totem pole you got
somebody at the top of the totem pole
that that's your big prize you're going
to indict people going up the totem pole
to see if you can squeeze them
threatened they're real a nation by loss
of Liberty and loss of property this is
the first of many steps in Bob Mullis
putting together an enormous puzzle Wow
what that's three you did three
metaphors you did Domino's totem pole
and then a puzzle that's very confusing
judge are we sure he's a judge I'm
pretty sure okay skipping Greg puzzle
boy Dana so when you hear the judge say
that he says it's a part of a puzzle
much more to come that's what we were
talking about in the last block to say
that I think this is a scratching the
surface this is what he started kicking
it off with and then they're gonna use
this what I did as a prosecutor you get
these people and then from them you pull
threads and they try to lure you roll it
up like a toothpaste tube just like
metaphor hell
toothpaste I I could totally follow to
everything that was going on I think one
thing that might have been a little bit
of a surprise today is that Rick Gates
gets brought up again because he people
sort of forgot about him he wasn't
somebody who was let go immediately as
manna for it was he stayed around on the
campaign he worked on the inaugural
committee or in the transition that
period right after the election and then
he worked on the inaugural committee so
I think that was a little bit of
surprise ago everyone forgot about him I
do think that in some ways people might
have been surprised today that it wasn't
Mike Flynn the former national security
adviser had been on the campaign trail
who we know has been in contact with
prosecutors in this case so I don't know
if there's more to come or not I just I
don't know I feel like it's pretty
locked up this guy the Papadopoulos got
arrested in July and we don't hear about
it until today I mean
it's a pretty tight operation I think
mm-hmm okay Jesse so when you hear them
talk about the you know there's more to
come etc I mean do you think you were
mentioning in the last block that you
really think perhaps they're gonna try
to use you know manna for to get him to
roll on if somebody closer etc to
president Trump's inner circle I think
you have to assume that there is major
international conspiracy and collusion
between Trump and Russia to buy into the
premise that he's just squeezing manna
for it in order to get the big fish
right what if there is no criminality
with Russia right so you're squeezing
manna for it well Peter King was saying
that he's been present in privy for some
of the actual testimony of people coming
in like Trump's lawyer and nothing so
far that he's heard he said suggests or
ties in anything to collusion with the
Russians the best they can hope to do
want is make kind of a tangential
connection to say well maybe to
President Trump and his team knew that
manna Ford had these connected but where
is the proof of that right well I think
it's a little different is the way I
would view it Kimberly because I think
one remember manna fort was at that
meeting in 2016 that was arranged by
Donald Trump jr. and so manna Ford is at
that meeting Jared Kushner's at that
Russian PR and then we learned last week
that the woman who was there in fact had
notes that had been coordinated with the
Russian government so she's at this
meeting she says oh I've got nothing to
open turns out she does have some
connection to the Russian government and
then you have manna fort who took notes
at this meeting and guess who has these
notes who recovered the notes I don't
know if you recovered them when he
busted into the guys house but he has
mana forts notes from that meeting so
he's gonna want to know from manna for
did what did you what happened at that
meeting and secondly was there follow-up
to it
so that lent leads and this is you know
how you were thinking you're saying well
there's no direct tie but if they know
that in fact the Russians are taking
certain steps then they are going to
take may be coordinated it's not
necessarily collusion by your definition
but my mind it would be hey these two
are working together okay so we went one
point two just to what Juan is speaking
to and Jesse and gets you to respond to
it now if you look at the specific
language in the indictment there's 13
wire transfer
when you do financial crimes cases like
this you follow the money you go back
and what it appears to me is that Muller
is really trying to stretch the timeline
by showing these series of 13 wires from
2012 to 2014 to show that it is actually
in sort of the Nexus of that timeframe
of the connection and a relationship
with you know President Trump and the
campaign etc so trying to like move it
down the right here - then where he
starts working you know for delegates
etc that's up to me that's what I see
that he's trying to do to rope it it
does the timeline stretch as far as 2016
because what I read it went to 2006 to
2024 2014 100% and then it says at least
on til 2016 so that is interesting
because you can say like for example say
I'm going to plead a case I've I'm gonna
charge a defendant and what what do we
always say we say honor about that you
know December 12th so it could be 11 it
could be the 13th and that's how you
cover it you put it sort of in yeah I
mean it's hard to speculate it's and it
seems like you'd know what you're
talking about just it looks like it wons
point - you're talking about the Russian
lawyer at the meeting at Trump Tower now
she's been tied to fusion GPS as well so
if you do pull the thread and we come
back to having Muller investigate fusion
GPS and we talked about Podesta not the
brother the actual campaign chair saying
to the Senate that he had no idea who
paid for this that seems like a lie and
it also seems like paying for Russian
dirt to influence election so and if his
brother Falls as well you could have the
same thing that happened with James
crank we're in the minute the Democrats
they love James Comey impeachable man of
integrity and then what happens in
October he turns things around and then
they start crushing or coat me again the
same thing could happen once the
Democrats fall they're gonna start
impeaching the integrity of Muller I
Spanish the island working for you it's
great I don't need any sons I'm to my
name tell the producers to shut up I
changed my name to Gutfeld a populist
so from now on you will address me as
Gutfeld a populace look what what about
what what do they have mana for da they
got him on money-laundering which is
essentially passing off the legal funds
as legit profits from a business how
different is that than hair and makeup
seriously look they take something awful
and they make it beautiful that's all it
is okay